what's the hardest piece of data
that you've been chasing that you've
chased in your life like what are some
interesting things because you mentioned
like one of the things you you kind of
want to go somewhere in the world
and find evidence and data for things
that people just haven't really looked
to get gain an understanding of human
nature maybe from an economics
perspective what's uh what what what
kind of stuff either in your past or in
your future you've been thinking about
well i mean the hardest
there's hard in two cents the hardest
emotionally was interviewing all those
kids in northern uganda that was just
like a gut punch every day
um
and just hearing the stories like that
was
the hardest but it wasn't hard because
it was you could the kids were
everywhere and everybody would talk to
you about it and they could talk about
it he could no one had gone and
interviewed
kids that had gone through war in the
middle of an active war zone nobody was
going to displace all the things we did
no one had done that before so
now lots of people do it could you
actually speak to their
their stories
what's like the shape of their suffering
what what were common themes what
how did that those stories change you
i remember i said you could you like
your dispassion itself and your
passion itself i think i had to learn to
create the dispassion itself i mean we
all have that capacity when we analyze
something that's far away and happens to
people different than us but you have to
i think i discovered and developed an
ability to like put those aside in order
to be able to study this so
um you get maybe harder
in a way that you have to be guarded
against so you have to try to remember
to put your human head on
it's really horrible like if i want to
conscript you
and i don't want you to run away then i
want to make you think you can never go
back to your village
and the best way for me to do that is
for to make you force you to do
something really really really really
horrible that you could you almost
incredibly believe you can never really
go back and it might be like killing a
loved one and so and just having hearing
people
tell you that story
in all the different shapes and forms to
a point what was horrible about it is
they did this so routinely that you'd be
sitting there in an interview with
somebody
and they'd be telling you the story and
it's like the most horrible thing that
could happen to you or anyone else
and and but there's some voice in the
back your mind saying okay
we really need to get to the other thing
you know we know that i know how this
goes like i've heard you know there's
this thing like okay okay i'm not
learning anything new here like there's
some part
you know deep evil terrible part of you
that's like yeah yeah yeah
like but let's get on to the other thing
but i know i have to go through this but
every day you have to go through that to
get to the because you're trying to
actually understand how to help people
you're trying to understand how that
trauma has manifested how they either
some people get stronger as a result of
that some people get weaker and if you
want to know how to help people then you
need to get to that i wasn't trying to
get to something for my selfish purposes
really i was trying to figure out okay
we need to know what your symptoms are
now it's such a dark thing about us
so if you're surrounded by trauma
oh god that voice in the back of your
head that you just go yeah i know
exactly how this conversation goes let's
skip ahead to the
to the solutions to the next yeah yeah
and then so that was that was yeah so
that was because you then you have to
deal with yourself so it's very helpful
if you like come home every night to
someone who's a gone through the same
thing and b is a professional and very
very very very good counseling
psychologist
um
the
the hardest thing i mean this the the
organized crime stuff has been the
hardest just figuring out how to get
that information it took us years
of just trial and error mostly error of
like just how to
get people to talk to us or how to
collect data
in a way that's safe for me and safe for
my team and safe for people to answer a
survey like how do you get
how do you get
the information on
what
gangs are doing in the community or how
it's hurting or helping people like
you've got to run surveys and you've got
to talk to gang members all these things
and that nobody knows how to do that
yeah and so we had to sort of really
slowly
not nobody there's a few other things
there's other academics like me who are
doing this but there's a pretty small
group
that's trying to like collect
systematic data and then there's a
slightly bigger
and much more experienced group that's
been talking to different armed groups
but every time you go to a new city and
there weren't that many people working
on this in medellin there are a few
you have to like discover a new like
it's it's really going to be unique to
that city and place
so there's not there's not like a
website for each of the 17 mafia groups
there's no there's no facebook group
there is now we have a we've created
like our own we have a private wiki
where we document everything and it's a
collaborative enterprise between lots of
researchers and journalists and things
so they now have they can't see you
can't go online and see this that's
that's individual researchers it's not i
mean they're hiding by design some of
them have facebook pages and things of
this nature so they they do have public
profiles a little bit but not
not exp not so explicitly no so they're
clandestine here's an example so one of
the things that's really endemic in
medellin is true in a lot of cities it's
true in american prisons is gangs govern
everybody's everyday life so if you have
a
in an american prison particularly
illinois or california texas is another
big one
but also
in a city in medellin if you have a
problem
um a debt to collect or dispute with a
neighbor or something
you could go to the government and and
they do and you they can help you solve
it you go to the police or you can go to
the gang
and so and that's like a really everyday
phenomenon but then there's a question
like how do you actually
how do you actually figure out how what
services they're offering and how much
they pay for them and do you actually
like those services and how do they how
do you comparison shop between the
police and the gang
and what would get you to go from the
gang to the police and then how's the
gang strategically going to respond to
that
and what was the impact of previous
policies to like make state governing
better and how did the gangs react and
so that's we had to sort of figure that
out and that that was um so that was
just hard in a different way but i don't
do the emotion the emotionally punishing
stuff i couldn't do any longer
so that's much easier in that sense
by the way and um
uh you know jorge ochoa some of these
folks are out of prison yeah have you
got a chance to talk to anybody by any
chance one of my collaborators on this
guy named gustavo duncan who's
who spent a lot of time interviewing
paramilitaries has written a book he's
talked to more of these people than i i
have um i haven't talked to
those and i i we haven't been talking to
them about this stuff but also they were
they were there in a different era yeah
so it doesn't the system was totally
different that's super interesting maybe
one day we'll do that
yeah if that was 30 years ago yeah and
the system over i mean la fissina pablo
escort created la fiscena he integrated
what's what the all these 17 resonates
and all these street gangs are the
fragmented former remnants of his more
unified empire which he gave the name la
fiscena i mean the i think you know it's
a little bit apocryphal but the idea is
you know i think he said um
every doctor has an office so should we
i still can't imag i i still love that
there's parallels between these uh mafia
groups and united nations yeah security
council this is just wonderful it's so
so so deeply human
you